i was sent an interesting video from a
sister on instagram uh to react to this
very video of chunks and his boy
young philly i'm guessing i think we
need to meet a couple because
we're not gonna get anywhere how was it
for you to open up
and and even so have you to some of your
family members is there people that
still don't know
can you see chunks there guys keep it
keep a close eye on him but you can see
he's uncomfortable
and as a muslim he has a right to be
he's never had a girlfriend he's like
that's aaron not everything i'm sorry
you know they are laughing they know
that they actually they don't believe
him they don't believe him watch this i
was like really
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum welcome to a better
career brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys ever inshallah i
was sent an interesting video from a
sister on instagram
uh to react to this very video of chunks
and his boy young philly or something
like that
yeah so um they're talking about it's a
love uh show basically talking about
couples how they make et cetera
let's get straight into it very
interesting things happened three things
happened very i i
and i noticed it and the sister who sent
that to me noticed and she was like
you realized that in the show let's get
straight into it inshallah and here we
go
we're guessing i think we need to meet a
couple because we're not going to get
anywhere
so they have no idea um chunks has no
idea who the couple is
in his head you know when today you
think about a couple it's just you know
male and female
well you can argue that yeah so this is
who the couple are you're
a lovely couple yeah i think the
representation of lesbians is very
white and very butch as well
and there's a whole spectrum we grew up
having
i want you guys to keep a close eye on
chunks's body language
and how he is keep a very close eye to
his
body language but let's hear the story
of these two um lesbians
very little kind of role models you know
you watch
movies love stories we don't see
ourselves in it and it almost makes you
feel
oh that's right you're not allowed to be
queer you know
what country are you from if you don't
mind me asking um actually my family are
all from west africa amazing
nigeria can you see chunks there guys
keep a close eye on him you know he's
he's i don't want to get him in trouble
with this like obviously i don't want to
point this out and you know because i
know how it is here
but you can see he's uncomfortable and
as a muslim has the right to be
uncomfortable not because of like you
know the two
persons opposite them but of what
they're promoting and what they're
living
uh by which again we're not asking for
hey we're just saying for example to
muslim standards i don't have to be okay
with that how was it for you to open up
and and even so have you to some of your
family members is there people that
still don't know
yeah like extended family in west africa
they don't know i mean
i feel like as i grew up and i became
more confident
i chose the family i wanted around me
the friends i want around me
because you can't please everybody and
now like i just really don't care
and she grew up in nigeria as a muslim
as well
so now she's seen that she's from
nigeria she's a muslim okay
and you can be a muslim what you're
doing is a sin
as long as you acknowledge that it is a
major sin and it is haram
yeah it says someone to commit an
adultery he knows it's a major sin he
knows this haram
if he says it is not haram and it's not
a major sin you fall into disbelief you
need to thought of islam it's as simple
as that
now the thing is here she's um openly
talking about it you know and like yes
i'm a muslim you know etc
the prophet salallahu sallam said that
the son of adam allah will forgive
everyone
except those who openly openly
promote their evilness yeah everyone
will be forgiven
okay it's that the discretion of god but
somebody who openly promotes it
will not be forgiven very important
let's carry on
it was yeah whilst growing up i knew it
would be very difficult to come out
there
because you know you can get imprisoned
or punished
you know by death as well in certain
places and it's
that is still not accepted um right now
and you know we are very fortunate to be
in a liberated country
where we can be ourselves and to be able
to be who we are
back then also my family were like
getting ready to marry off my cousins
and stuff like that
and they were pretty young they were
like you know 16 and they were gonna be
oh when you're 18 you'll be married
oh we have this person yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's very very normal
i don't care about how her family feels
about
her i don't care if the how the whole
society feels about her if the whole
society
dislikes her i'm not really concerned
about that in that context where their
emotions and their feelings i'm not
really that concerned what i'm concerned
about guys is because
i'm more concerned about the laws and
legislation that you're violating
if god exists which we have evidence to
you're living in his land
his earth his planet yeah he's the one
who feeds you sustains you looks after
you gives you your health
the least that you can do is that if you
have certain tendencies
is to fight it off yeah and i'm not
saying you have to i'm saying
you can choose to yeah you can say no i
don't want to in this country you can be
gay homosexual
whatever you like no one can say nothing
to you in an islamic perspective always
say this guys
the worship of god is that you put him
first beyond everything
forget what people think forget that
it's about how do you feel about
violating the legislation of god
almighty yeah and he can help you
overcome that that is what's really
important let's go to a verse in the
quran allah subhanahu wa times and this
is very profound brothers and sisters
here
have you seen o prophet those who take
that
those who have taken their own desires
as their god
and so allah left them to stray
knowingly seal their hearing
and heart and place the cover on their
side who then can guide them after allah
will you all not then be mindful allah
says here
have you not seen the one who takes his
desires this god brothers and sisters we
all of us are tested with different
things yeah we all have weaknesses
towards other
variety of things it could be anything
money it can be gambling it can be
alcohol it can be women it could be the
opposition it can be homosexual
tendencies
however islam is saying the following
understand and accord you have a lord
because there are people who have
homosexual tendencies who are homosexual
or
a lesbian yeah or whatever they may be
but
they choose to fight that yeah now
that's not your discretion i'm not
saying you have to
they choose to fight it because when
you're fighting you're saying i am not
going to take my desire as my god
because the moment you say i'm going to
take my desires my god what you're
saying is this
yeah that you're saying i'm not going to
acknowledge you god i have these desires
i'm going to act upon it
allah is the one who created the heavens
and the earth yeah
he can help you overcome that he can
help you if you want to willingly he can
help you overcome that
there are certain things that i was
addicted to in my jahilia
and while i also be life if we used to
think to myself i think i'm going to
fall back into that
i used to hate the sin but asking allah
for help
i overcame that i was i overcame it
i could have come and said you know what
i'm going to take my desire as my god
and i'm going to do as i please and
let's watch now when this guy asks a
round of applause yeah okay
let's watch trunks carefully
[Laughter]
that's amazing you see what's happening
now guys is that
this thing is become becoming normalized
okay it's become normal and the thing is
with the queer community they have
guidelines as well like you know when
when it comes to the
the the pedophilia movement where
they're saying that they're born in that
way and they want their rights to join
them
they say no that's wrong you kind of
incest the ones who want to commit
instead no no you can't do that
you see even to their standards they're
saying no there are red lines
who draws those red lines we come and
say for example that
it's a red line for example certain acts
to happen but
as homosexuals or lesbians but the thing
is you also have certain lines that you
don't want to cross
who decides what's right or wrong we're
living in a time look at what
trunks says and look how they look what
they react to and
not knowing that they actually deny they
don't believe what's about to be said
and that tells you a lot listen to this
carefully guys it's very profound watch
this
imagine i was single for two years
before i met her so
he's never had a girlfriend he's left
that's aaron not everything today
you know they are laughing thinking it's
a joke
they're literally thinking they know
that they actually
they don't believe him they don't
believe him watch this i was like really
yes chance actually
doesn't have a girlfriend i'm definitely
[Laughter]
she loves and saying hi he and he he
never had a girlfriend
yeah he never had a girlfriend why can
you get guys please i'm going to end on
this not yet forget
guys please don't put my glasses on
rough yeah man he's full focus on this
he is the odd one out there he in that
video he's the odd one out you don't
have a girlfriend
he didn't commit zina you know her you
know
so he is he he
he is how we all should be not he'd have
a girlfriend
one thing absolute chunks yeah is that
he is a bit uncomfortable in the context
i don't think there's anything personal
against him i don't have anything
personal against these two i genuinely
don't i'm talking about the sin that's
been committed yeah and if they were to
say to me we will hang you ali
inshallah i don't speak big yeah i would
say this
over and over again it is haram it's a
major sin even if you cut
us into pieces with allah gives us
strength inshallah
and maybe one day it might come to that
that you force your views on us here
it's a sin and it is a sin and unless
destroyed nations over it
no one can come and force that down our
throat and we will stick by that
i don't like the fact that how trunks is
made to be the odd one out
i never had a girlfriend trunks you
should be proud you should say i want
this video to be set to trunks
chunks you should be proud you know why
i salute you brother you're in a certain
field etc whatever maybe i don't agree
with everything you do i've especially
been in this
specific um thing but however i salute
you that you don't have a girlfriend may
allah bless you
you seem like a good brother who wants
to get married the right way
keep it like that if you do not let
anyone pressurize you to make you feel
as if
you're strange you're not strange yeah
you're not strange
other people are strange you're not so
um make that very clear inshallah and
he's
in in that very instance we salute you
that like allah says
do you not even come close to it that
you don't even have a girlfriend and
keep it that way i can't get married
inshallah
and may let me i'll give you a blessed
marriage a righteous
wife inshallah and you guys and
inshallah both you know both
righteous uh together the thing is
brothers and sisters the reason why i
wanted to react to this
is that how the norms have changed how
the norms have changed today
that they're putting certain romantic
certain sad songs and making it feel
bad etc and i'm so sorry you know i'm so
sorry they can have their way of life
but sadly today the lgbqt movement is
moving so much
that they are now forcing down our
throat so much so to the very curriculum
that they're teaching at
schools at schools and they're pushing
this down our throat
yeah and this is very important you want
to live your way of life you go ahead
but don't push me to that
and that's why i wanted to do this video
about the two lesbians
and chunks's statement of not having a
girlfriend and i salute him for that i
don't want to keep the video too much
longer share this with your friends and
families hope you guys benefited from
this inshallah may allah subhanahu wa
keep us protected on the straight path
inshallah we're in this life for a
reason there's a purpose
may god enable us to fight of the
desires that we have
that is not pleasing to him and for us
to acknowledge that he is the true one
that
deserves to be worshipped and that the
least that we can do on this earth that
he's brought us into
and sustains us to obey his commandments
and not be like no it's what i want it's
about
me it's the reverse it's not about you
it's about the one who created you
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh